okay so I had to do this video because I
was searching on the internet for diet
and the first three to four pages are
just covered with false information so
if you're new to dieting this video is
for you I'm going to make it really
really simple and I hope you get to this
video before the other ones because it's
gonna save you a lot of grief so there's
a misconception that most people have
about dieting when they get into dining
that the weight loss is equal to the fat
loss in other words if they lose weight
they're losing actual fat that is
absolutely not true when you change your
diet
most people will lose some water weight
in the first two weeks and then they
will plateau and if they think that's
fat they're setting themselves up for a
whole bunch of confusion following that
because then you're gonna get more bad
advice and exercise more because it's
all about calories and you're gonna eat
less okay now during this time you're
craving you're hungry and you're eating
more carbs and that's really why you
gain the weight back or you actually
might have stopped the weight loss but
these two actions right here are not
going to help you because look at this
too much insulin will just lock up the
release of this fat you cannot release
fat if there's too much insulin so what
keeps this lock on this fat and prevents
you from using it is the stored sugar
that you have and also the carbs in the
bloodstream so the two things the most
important crucial things to put all your
attention on is just to deplete the
stored sugar and reduce your carbs how
do you do that you eat less frequent you
do intermittent fasting that is going to
deplete the stored sugar and you can
also add exercise to speed it up as well
and also you must eat less carbs so
therefore they'll be less stored and
then this lock will open up and you can
start releasing fat that's the most
important thing these other things will
not help you eating less fat higher
protein or less protein a plant-based
eating healthier it really has to do
with these two things right here
alright so
a new person I suggest that you watch
the link down below to get the full
story of how to do this with all the
details thanks for watching
hey if you enjoyed this video press
subscribe and I will definitely keep you
updated